everyone always has these grand
aspirations about life when I grow up
I'm going to do this need this person
I'm going to make a name for myself
I'm going to be some you know always
these big dreams I was the same I wanted
that big job that big house that fast
car Olive didn't get it though not even
close
I ended up here instead 37 years at this
place God hasn't been that long first
two years told myself it was going to be
a temporary thing I was going to move on
get that big house
it was only for the paycheck supposed to
help the wife and feed the baby
but then baby number two came well two
years turned into five and five years
turned into two it's funny how things
change how your perspective changes you
grow up you get married and have kids
learning a lot of stuff they told you
when you were young it was just [ __ ]
I've always been about lessons and
moments that's all life is just a series
of moments not things not once
just simple honest to god
that hopefully add up to you living a
decent life and being a good person it
really it's always been a little moments
that you remember over everything else
city weighs the smile loved ones the
sound of their voice in the morning
how easy their hand fit into yours I
didn't plan on ending up this desk but
it was where life took me I didn't get
the dream I got a life instead and it
was more than I could have ever asked
for
Wow